22.000 menschen sind derzeit an corinna
virus in deutschland erkrankt heute wird
darüber entschieden ob wir deutschland
deutschland weiter ausgangs
beschränkungen brauchen angela merkel
telefoniert dazu mit den länderchefs es
scheint so als würde es eine breite
unterstützung im land geben denn unsere
kliniken laufen sonst wie in italien die
gefahr dass sie überlastet werden dass
wir all diese patienten nicht mehr so
behandeln können wie sie es verdienen
und wie sie es brauchen mir zugeschaltet
um die situation in den krankenhäusern
zu besprechen sind jetzt thomas menzl
chef des klinikums in fulda und
professor dr clemens alexander grimm er
ist der chef anästhesist in dem klinikum
herzlichen dank dass ihr uns
zugeschaltet sind sagen sie wie ist die
situation jetzt gerade in klinikum fulda
haben sie das gefühl dass die maßnahmen
die der gesundheitsminister angekündigt
hat mehrere milliarden zur verfügung zu
stellen
jetzt eine situation schaffen mit denen
die krankenhäuser in deutschland klar
kommen können
klinikum fulda ist die situation im
krankenhaus derzeit noch an sie ton von
mir hallo am klinikum fulda ist die
situation noch ruhig
technik zu regeln bitte sprechen wir
noch mal ja sagen wir noch mal von vorn
herein klinikum selbst ist die situation
noch ruhig wir gehen ja dann auch gleich
reinschalten aus meiner sicht sind die
krankenhäuser insgesamt in dieser wiese
eine ganz wichtige rolle spielen werden
sie spielen denn dort wird ja die
versorgung der patienten statt was für
uns wichtig ist dass wir in dieser zeit
das geld was wir brauchen auch wirklich
bekommen kein krankenhaus will an dieser
krise geld verdienen wir wollen nur
unseren betrieb weiterlaufen lassen
dafür braucht es liquidität kaufen
material wir bezahlen unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
gleichzeitig haben wir das was wir sonst
machen dass die patienten die wir
operieren die patienten die wir alec
tief behandeln die wir jetzt verschieben
nicht mehr in der klinik bei uns ist im
moment fast die hälfte der betten leer
weil die auf den ansturm der kuna
patienten warten und das was vorgelegt
wurde von der bundesregierung gestern
abend hat einen sturm der entrüstung
ausgelöst weil ganz vielen
krankenhäusern und und diesem
hintergrund brauchen wir da eine
nachbesserung
das bundesgesundheitsministerium
minister sparen hat schon auch
entsprechend reagiert es gibt eine erste
hinweis dass wir da eine nachbesserung
bekommen das was derzeit auf dem tisch
liegendes unzureichend und wird dazu
führen dass möglicherweise krankenhäuser
mitten in der korona krise insolventen
ja herr professor dr greim ist uns jetzt
auch direkt aus der intensivmedizin
zugeschaltet herr professor dr
wie viele kroner patienten haben sie
denn derzeit im klinikum fulda und haben
sie das gefühl dass sie der excel dem
ansturm der da kommen könnte gewappnet
sind
und ja wir haben uns gestern ja
eigentlich noch in einem ruhe vor dem
sturm befunden und wir haben die letzten
wochen dafür nutzen können uns
strategisch person ehren auch materiell
auf diese zu erwartende welle
einzustellen die ihr drehbuch mäßig muss
man sagen auch in deutschland auftritt
wir haben jetzt derzeit bei uns im
landkreis etwa 80 patienten die positiv
getestet sind und wir ja im klinikum
fulda in der letzten nacht den ersten
schwerkranken intensiv pflichtigen
patienten aufnehmen müssen den wir jetzt
tatsächlich auch mit einem
extrakorporalen lungen
unterstützungssystem behandeln stehen
denn von diesen geräten diesen
beatmungsgeräten verdienen ist ja immer
heiß davon gibt es in deutschland zu
wenig und das wird uns irgendwann m
wirklich probleme schaffen stehen da
genug geräte zur verfügung
man muss einmal unterscheidet zwischen
normalen beatmungsgeräten
hier haben wir in deutschland sicherlich
reserven die für die nächsten wochen
ausreichend werden es gibt aber diese
sogenannten extrakorporalen verfahren
die nur in wenigen krankenhäusern
vorhanden sind das sind in der regel die
größeren universitätskliniken und es
sind auch größere krankenhäuser für das
klinikum fulda erzählt dazu und ist in
der lage bis zu sechs patienten mit
diesem extrakorporalen verfahren zu
behandeln
das ist schon mal eine sehr stattliche
zahl denn wir rechnen nicht damit dass
jeder patient der kogit erkennt ist und
dann auch intensiv pflichtig wird gleich
mit einem solchen besonderen gerät
behandelt werden muss in der regel wird
es so sein dass diese patienten zunächst
ein akutes lungenversagen entwickelt und
hierfür für deren behandlung sind wir
bestens gewappnet und könnten im
extremen fall in der sofort situation 30
intensivpatienten unproblematisch
behandeln ja herr doktor greim und herr
dr menzel ich würde ihnen gerne dieses
video einer krankenschwester aus berlin
zeigen die doch etwas berichtet was
einem durchaus sorgen
kinderkrankenschwester auf der
flüchtlingskinder intensiv dass hier in
berlin dass wir in unseren schutz haben
denn eigentlich gene mäßig nicht mehr
vernünftig nutzen können und mehrfach
nutzen müssen und das einfach zu viele
leute privathaushalt mundschutz kaufen
und haben der eigentlich gar nicht
benötigt wird ist für die kranke und für
die immungeschwächten jahr aber in
unserem klinikalltag fehlt es einfach
momentan so dass es teilweise sogar ohne
grund zu operieren müssen weil sie
keinen vernünftigen mehr herr dr mansell
wenn man so etwas hört chirurgen
operieren ohne mundschutz zuerst die
frage an sie als chef einer klinik
meinen sie dass solche zustände auch
bald in ganz deutschland eintreffen
können nun wir hoffen nicht die
situation den einzelnen krankenhäusern
ist unterschiedlich was die persönliche
schutzausrüstung angeht bei uns im
klinikum fulda haben wir derzeit noch
genug aber ich kann gar nicht dicke noch
unterstreichen was die krankenschwester
aus berlin gesagt hat es ist blödsinn
diese sachen zu hause zu horten ihr
brauchen sie in den krankenhäusern damit
ihr uns schützen können und unsere
patienten schützen können und alles das
was außerhalb des krankenhauses abläuft
kann ohne masken und ohne
desinfektionsmittel und ähnliches
ablaufen ich glaube dass wir jetzt
insgesamt in ganz deutschland viele
anstrengungen unternehmen ich weiß dass
auch dass wir mehr material schutz
material bekommen
teilweise wird in china auch schon
wieder produziert dort wo wir ja auch in
der vergangenheit muss man klar sagen
das meiste dieser materialien produziert
eingekauft haben das geht jetzt ein
stückchen weise wieder an und ich hoffe
dass wir diese phase großen so knapp ist
dann gut überbrücken können leider
stellen wir natürlich auch fest dass
alle länder versuchen für sich selber zu
arbeiten es gibt exportverbote es gibt
an unterschiedlichen stellen
einschränkungen im handel das macht das
ganze natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger
und es führt zu ungleichgewichten und
ich finde es sehr bedauerlich dass das
passiert und kauf dass die politik da
eine lösung findet dass wir da wieder
alle gemeinsam daran arbeiten dass das
funktioniert und dass wir ausgleichen
was wir mehr haben was woanders weniger
als 20 gutes beispiel dass in baden
württemberg jetzt auch in
den kliniken patienten aus frankreich
behandelt werden das ist das richtige
signal ja auch was die versorgung einen
ball betrifft scheint deutschland oft
noch ein flickenteppich zu sein auch die
fahrerfrage herrn professor dr
haben sie das gefühl dass sie von der
bundesregierung so ausgestattet werden
dass sie auf eine große welle
vorbereitet sind aus meiner persönlichen
meinung hat die bundesregierung
eigentlich sehr früh richtig reagiert
auf die nahende infektion zu ende und
die richtigen maßnahmen ergriffen was
die wirtschaftlichkeit der krankenhäuser
angeht was die finanzielle
sicherstellung der von uns bringenden
leistungen angeht damit sie den
kommentar von dr mansell von gehört das
kann nicht nur unterstreichen
meine meinung ist und ich möchte das
noch mal betonen was der mensch so dazu
schon gesagt hat dass die krankenhäuser
unmittelbar jetzt liquide bleiben müssen
wir müssen für materialien für alles was
wir bei unseren patienten benötigen
jetzt die mittel zur verfügung haben und
es darf nicht bei versprechungen bleiben
dass irgendwann nach der krise diese
ganzen investitionen nachträglich
finanziert werden
das wird die krankenhäuser an den rande
des kollapses bringen
da muss es schon einiges lösungen geben
gesundheitsminister sparen hat er
versprochen nachzubessern
dennoch würde ich ihnen die herren gerne
nochmal dieses video einer ärztin aus
italien zeigen das land es in europa am
meisten von corona virus betroffen ist
und mittlerweile mehr tote als china zu
verzeichnen hat aktuell haben wir in
cremona 40 patienten auf der
intensivstation obwohl wir in unserem
krankenhaus kapazitäten für zehn
schwerstkranke haben deshalb werden die
kollegen aus der anästhesie leider dazu
gezwungen zu entscheiden wen sie
intensiv behandeln und an die geräte
anschließen und wenn ich zwischen einem
jüngeren und einem älteren patienten
müssen sie sich leider für den jüngeren
entscheiden
herr professor dr greim wird das auch
deutschland treffen können
dieses dramatische dieses dramatische
appell der ärztin dass wir uns
entscheiden müssen zwischen einem
älteren patienten und einem jüngeren
patienten und uns im prinzip bewusst als
arzt dafür entscheiden müssen patienten
sterben zu lassen
ja also ich glaube und hoffe dass das
weit von uns entfernt licht und nicht
real wird allerdings ist deutschland ein
land das sich schon immer auch damit
auseinandergesetzt hat dass es zu einem
massenanfall von verletzten oder eben
auch einen massenanfall von infizierten
kommen kann und deswegen gibt es auch in
der notfallmedizin diese sogenannten
triage systeme die die kolleginnen
gerade angesprochen hat für die nächsten
wochen halte ich dies für deutschland
für sehr unwahrscheinlich also die
notwendigkeit das anzuwenden weil nach
meinem eindruck erstens die intensiv
ausstattung pro einwohner deutlich
besser bei uns in deutschland ist als in
italien und insgesamt das
gesundheitssystem strukturelle
personelle und auch ausstattungs
technische vorteile auf herr doktor
menzel auf die frage an sie als chef des
krankenhauses befürchten sie auch nicht
zustände wie in italien und können dort
zumindest vorerst entwarnung geben
ja das sind schlimme bilder die uns
daraus italien erreichen und auch die
wissenschaftlichen artikel die jetzt
deutschland kompliziert werden die uns
übrigens helfen das einzuschätzen was
auf uns zukommen kann sind sehr wertvoll
aber auch sehr bestürzt aus meiner sicht
schließe ich mich den worten von
professor kroymann
wir hoffen dass das bei uns nicht so
passiert
wir gehen davon aus dass ihr aufgrund
der höheren kapazitäten in der
intensivmedizin solche zustände
vermeiden können
aber wirklich wissen tut das heute
keiner
es bleibt trotzdem aus unserer sicht da
die zuversicht die ganz klar dominant
ist und wir tun alles im klinikum fulda
in den anderen krankenhäusern wir sind
mit den kollegen sehr gut vernetzt wir
sind in ständigen kontakt und austausch
das bundesland hessen in dem fuldaer
liegt hat jetzt auch einen ganz neuen
planungsstab ins leben gerufen der sich
abstimmt natürlich telefon
oder eine video-konferenz wir haben in
den einzelnen regionen jetzt
koordinierende häuser eingesetzt
damit wir wissen was in unseren
versorgungsregionen passiert als das
zentral zusammen läuft und dass wir in
einer region wie unserer das ist aus
hessen im herzen von deutschland
untereinander vernetzt sind es gibt noch
andere krankenhäuser dort und es ist
wichtig dass das gesteuert und
koordiniert wird diese aufgabe haben
jetzt übertragen bekommen in den anderen
bereichen in hessen die großen kliniken
auch das ist noch mal ein ganz wichtiger
schritt dass wir wissen wo sind
kapazitäten wo können wir menschen hin
schicken und auch die niedergelassenen
kolleginnen und kollegen will ich nicht
unerwähnt lassen die wirklich einen
großartigen job machen mit den ganzen
kuchen patienten die zwar krank sind
aber nicht so krank dass sie ins
krankenhaus müssen das sind ja zum glück
das darf man nicht vergessen 80 prozent
die patienten brauchen keinen
krankenhaus maximal sind es zehn prozent
die ins krankenhaus müssen wie du merken
gar nicht dass sie den effekt haben
auch das sollten wir dann schon auch in
berücksichtigung ziehen die
niedergelassenen kollegen machen darauf
guten job und alle gemeinsam sind wir
vorbereitet alle gemeinsam haben wir die
bilder gesehen aus italien und alle
gemeinsam wollen sie verhindern dass
solche bilder aus deutschland kommen
herr dr menzel vielen herzlichen dank
auch ihnen professor dr klein für diese
einschätzungen die uns ein wenig
zuversicht geben vielen dank nach fulda